so one of the things that I wanted to
discuss today was what you think a good
life looks like and we've already
touched on that not necessarily doing
things for their sake doing them because
they feel like something that's valuable
to you not doing them for external
validation but how do you define a good
life what does a good life look like to
you ah I think a good life is a life
that leaves it's a life that the
signature that life is something that
you've experienced you've really lived
you really first of all you have to
really live life you know I think the
aesthetics the people who've like denied
the pleasures of the body and been in a
path of renunciation where they're just
kind of isolating themselves or going to
a monastery I respect that path but I
don't think that to me is the path that
most of us should take I think we're
here to live on the earth to really
experience all the things to eat the
food to try the drinks to try the you
know to try the drugs not all the not
all the drugs but some of them at least
rogues I select drugs yeah like it's
like do the things don't abuse them you
know like don't go you don't go wild but
like experience all the things that go
visit the beautiful places like dip in a
cold water fall and feel rain fall on
your face and you know go to a hot
desert and climb a snowy mountain and do
all of these things surf and ski and
play and dance and make love and and do
all the things that we're here to do I
think think that's a big part of it it's
just to open yourself up to that I think
another part is to feel our connection
you know spiritually to everything
around us to that source energy the
universe God if you promise your
language permits it whatever your
language permits you to feel as far as
the spiritual experience I think that's
a unique expression of what we're able
to do here so it's both the carnal and
the spiritual it's the physical and the
astral kind of dancing together and then
the other thing is to just make sure
that you've left the world and everybody
you've touched a little better for you
having been here and I think that's the
to service you know so experience
everything but also leave everybody that
you touch and everybody every place that
you go a little more enriched and a
little more colorful and and vibrant
then then when you found it and if you
do that and that's a good life to me
[Music]